you're watching swipe here's what we've
got for you in the next ten minutes
Thomas meets the eight-year-old who
might just be Britain's answer to Bill
Gates I can interconnected computers I
play games on the computers I do
mathematics on the computers meanwhile I
go on board the bus touring schools to
offer a bit of texture ation hello
everyone
[Applause]
and we're taking back control summary
evil heartless in our games review
welcome to swipe if you're a regular
viewer you'll know we often look at
technology that's trying to help
children get into computing but let's
face it some of those children are
already there with bailed on this week
Thomas has been to see what a typical
day is like when you're the world the
youngest microsoft certified
professional he'll explain what that
means music had mozart and painting had
Picasso now computing has its own child
prodigy iron Qureshi spends his day like
any other child his age French verbs PE
lessons and learning about that old
favorite ancient Egypt but it's when he
gets home that his true talent surfaces
3 when I started to explore the hard
world the computers and the hardware is
like the parts you can touch like the
keyboard the monitor and all that I can
install and to think of the operating
system of the computers I can transfer
the data from one computer to another
I can interconnect the computers I play
games on the computers I do mathematics
on the computers and I give just the
physical connectivity between computers
just 5 years old he passed a prestigious
exam making him the youngest ever
Microsoft Certified Professional
he's even built from scratch his very
own computer lab I passed a computer
exam at the lingam City University it
was a Microsoft exam with many different
types of questions I can't remember the
exact number of questions but there were
quite a few
I am skills on a desktop mean he's
become quite popular with his teachers
you can teach us a few things he knows
how to you know any problems with the
computer oriented to go person which is
obviously very useful his clear iron is
an exceptional computer scientists perm
as demand for people with his kind of
skills grows they were doing enough to
let them flourish
Jill runs out of school camps for kids
wanting to learn a range of digital
skills code in computing she
schools don't currently allow students
with an aptitude for IT to blossom
there's a huge digital skills gap in
every country in the US and UK in Europe
in no countries are we able to provide
as many people who have the digital and
technology skills as the economy's going
to require so if we want to keep that
value if we want to keep that creative
piece of that value and if we want to be
able to deliver all the different
innovations that we need for our
economies especially here in Europe we
have to develop that talent and we have
to create the opportunities for kids to
develop that talent but for now we wait
great things from iron he's dreaming big
I want to be an IT entrepreneur in the
future and I would also like to set up
an e-value in the UK and ebuddy will be
the biggest technology have a deal Kay
watch this space
Thomas Newton Sky News in a moment we'll
be on the bus letting students test
drive air deck that's education tech by
the way it's coming right up after a
roundup of this week's tech news Airbus
wants to start testing a flying car by
the end of this year the self piloted
prototype which will look something like
this is part of project vahana and one
of the aerospace companies ways of
avoiding traffic the firm's not the only
one working on flying cars among others
is Slovakian start-up era Mobile which
began testing its prototype in 2014
China has started experiments using the
world's first quantum satellite its main
job is apparently to explore hack-proof
communications by relaying secure keys
from space to earth the satellite will
also be used to investigate quantum
entanglement the strangest phenomenon in
quantum physics apples putting up the
cost of apps in the UK creating a price
parity between the dollar and the pound
for the first time app that used to cost
79 P will now be 99 P while US customers
pay 99 cents it follows the fall and the
value of the pound
and mobile phone company he was handed a
fine of 2.7 million pounds for
overcharging nearly 40,000 customers
Ofcom said the company didn't intend to
make money from its filling mistake but
it didn't try to reimburse customers
until the regulator intervened those
affected were overcharged by around
250,000 pounds in total stick around for
our games review in just a few minutes
with jumping high and slamming hard in
gravity rush - well while Thomas was
busy getting computing tips from iron
this week I went to visit a school in
London to see how a bus is helping offer
pupils the chance to shine in tech not
often you see a 40-foot American School
Bus
in a British program but this is nice
hello everyone yellow bus around the
country and we're driving technology
into schools helping schools push
technology in this country and giving
teachers and and you know students the
opportunity to see lots of different
tech that they might not experience
isn't this really the job of the school
or the teachers should they be doing
this teachers have got loads on their
plate already we really overload with
too much technologies is an industry you
know it goes like that really fast so
for a teacher to kind of look up look at
technology it's too much so you know
even for us geeks in the industry you
know it's going really far so for us
it's helping the teachers finding the
best attack that has educational value
and actually bringing it in helping the
teachers and the children learn about
tech and where are you getting your
funding from to do all this
a bokor the funding has come from myself
personally some of our initial suppliers
who've had the forethought have also
invested some money into the bus to help
us push it forward and as we grow I'm
sure we'll get more supplies involved
and more investment so what's your
favorite bit about being on the ideas
but I think my favorite bit is that we
get to experience new technology that's
happening around the world and it would
be really fun for kids to experience
that because you don't see that every
day
when you're older do you want to do a
job that involves anything you don't
like about it
you've got somehow happy customers here
then having like a zoo we do video games
time now and as we move away from the
festive period we're starting to see if
you're the bigger titles being released
now here's Lucy with a review gravity
rush - is the long awaited sequel to
2012 gravity rush a game that has a
really cool concept and gameplay
mechanic so while you're controlling the
main character hat you're also kind of
manipulating the gravity around you so
in gravity rush - you can manipulate
gravity in the usual way to make you go
up and float in the sky and then come
down but you can also manipulate it to
make you speed and make you more agile
make it go through the air faster
the developers have really tried to make
it a more complete experience you can
interact with all these different
characters it's very colorful very
Japanese and if you feel like you're
missing out on the first game came out
on the PlayStation Vita they also kind
of made a nice shiny new version for the
PlayStation 4 called gravity rush
remastered so you can play that too
Yakuza zero is a prequel to the accuser
series it takes place in a fictionalized
version of Tokyo of a fictional version
of a suburb of Shinjuku which is kind of
like the red-light district takes place
about 17 years before the main series of
games it is a prequel when you take
control of Goro and Kazuma you are very
famous if you play the things before
you'll know their stories and they've
been in pretty much every installment I
think of the main series so you wander
around Tokyo and you aren't you're not
really the crime boss yet you have to
kind of prove your work to the Yakuza by
brawling and kind of taking control of
the district what's interesting about
this game is that if you've been to
Tokyo or Osaka then you'll definitely
recognize a lot of the locations the
vibe is very similar and it's a really
cool game and it's definitely worth
checking out if you're into
if you've never played Kingdom Hearts
before then Kingdom Hearts HD 2.5 -
prologue might not be the best place to
jump in the basic premise of the game is
its Square Enix is Final Fantasy
characters made Disney characters so
you'll have a character named Sora and
his two buddy is Donald and Goofy and
you go around all these different Disney
worlds and meet the characters there and
take it back from the control of the
evil heartless but what people are
really excited about is Kingdom Hearts
no point to birth by Sleep which is a
kind of a prologue going into Kingdom
Hearts 3 so connects the story between
one of the spin-off games birth by Sleep
and Kingdom Hearts 3 it's also gonna be
the first time that we'll actually get
to play on the new engine that's been
used for Kingdom Hearts 3 it uses some
of the tech so I mean Kingdom Hearts 2 I
think came out in about 2006 and so
people are really easily just grasping
onto anything Kingdom Hearts in the
run-up to 3 so if you're a big fan
definitely recommend picking up 2.8
that's it for this week but don't forget
you can watch any of our swipe episodes
on demand and all the usual places and
follow us on Twitter at Sky News fight
to see that we get up to throughout the
week I'll be back next week hope you can
join us then bye-bye
[Music]